well first on CBS this morning we're  revealing a new Superbowl PSA that  empowers young girls to get in the game  CBS partnered with Girls Inc for a new  CBS cares public service announcement  it's voiced by our very own Gayle King  and features a team of young girls who  face off against the New York Giants the  goal is to encourage girls to believe  that they can succeed at the highest  level in any field especially when  working together when girls face their  challenges they're stronger when girls  work together they realize their value  when girls get to play they learn to win  I love it you can see the PSA again this  Sunday during Super Bowl 53 right here  on CBS